also bei einer solchen frage wo es darum
geht das betrifft ja mehrere million
menschen und ist europaweit ja einmalig
bei einer solchen frage wo es darum geht
zu fragen gibt's tatsächlich
wissenschaftliche evidenz für eine
solche maßnahme dafür ist der
expertenrat gebildet worden und dann
frage ich mich wenn eine solche
entscheidung getroffen werden soll
vielleicht wird im expertenrat hier an
dann würde ich dem expertenrat mal ein
bisschen nachfragen was ich alle davon
halten und mich nicht darauf verlassen
dass die studie nahe von denen ich bin
jurist wie sie essen kein mediziner aber
im logischen denken dazu geneigt die vom
rk ii ran gebende studien geben die
entscheidung nicht her damit kann man
sie nicht begründen und wie gesagt es
gibt die überlegung dass man nach drei
monaten schon wieder infektiös sein kann
das stimmt aber es geht für die
künftigen gleicher weise und das war
auch vorher schon so das ist seine
erkenntnis sehr richtig und das ist auch
eine sehr interessante spur in der frage
was hier passiert ist also wenn man das
vorhat den genesenen status so
dramatisch zu verkürzen und kann hat
einen expertenrat dem der chef des rk
angehört dann kann man doch von dem lkw
chef erwarten dass er die kollegen dort
im expertenrat fragt bevor er
entscheidet und new york ist und haben
da kann man von der regierung der ich
angehöre auch erwarten dass sie auf
europäischer ebene seien erklärte wird
er könnte ja sechs erinnerte dritten
hinterfrage er übergibt sie zurecht
gehören der regierung an manchmal merkt
man das nicht so ganz aber doch im
gegensatz zur union sind oder kleine
keine fabrik eine kleine organisation wo
wir wo einer gefehlt
die waren eben große kanzlerin hat ihn
besteht darin dass gerade unsere eigene
meinung cup zu einem wunderbar als ganz
kurz gefragt weil man nach olaf scholz
hochs olaf scholz da kommen wir
also man kann hier aber ganz
gerne regierung an der expertenrat wurde
ja von ihrer regierung mit eingesetzt
aber ist so christian lindner haben sie
denn mal angerufen und gefragt wurde
christa lehrerin christa lindner ja wir
haben darüber gesprochen
der war genauso überrascht wie ich erst
mal vorher freundlich zu formulieren und
vor allem vize vizekanzler und vor
einigen war überrascht davon dass
deutschland gleichzeitig im eigenen land
die genese des staates auf drei monate
reduziert und europa im gleichen tag auf
europäischer ebene dafür stimmt das aber
sechs monaten bleibt also dieser diese
diskrepanz muss dies auch
aufklärungsbedürftige wusste das
auswärtige habe ich was ist nun das
ministerium macht und um in teheran
wegen der armut land viele neue
verankern
die die regierung die wiesbaden ist noch
beim boarding ist wir bilden neue
ministerien die abteilung gern umgesetzt
hat sehr gespannt auf die 105
für das bis märz man sagt immer 100 tage
ist so dass man sich einrichten kann
wir sind ja nicht so ganz zufrieden
hatte noch beim boarding oder biologisch
aber danach nachdem wir zwei jahre cars
politiker und angela
merkel noch schulter verkürzung des
gelesenen sterne hin dass die ersten
aber doch
art und weise politik und wenn ich merke
wie der glänzende jens spahn im dezember
letzten jahres
doch der beste und
an die wand gespielt nicht also er mich
fragt gerade was würde ich es bürgern
ist für mich fast wenn ihr dann auch so
im bundestag sitzt diskutiert ihr dann
mehr darüber ob jetzt entspannt blöder
war oder angela merkel habe er immer
näher und wolfgang kuck mal so eine
einheit nur vor gericht war für mich
wenn ich höre dass die regierung nicht
eigentlich gar nicht richtig dass es mit
dem genesenen schades vorher wusste dass
mich schockiert das ganze das heißt
eigentlich ist es eine frage herr
kubicki kann es sein dass morgen wieder
irgend regel beschlossen wird die
vielleicht ja auch wirklich der
vizekanzler christa länder gar nicht gut
findet auch gar nicht weiß ist ja ein
riesiges tobago ja das will ich nur so
nicht sagen aber es lohnt sich genauer
hinzuschauen
bei aller liebe ich finde es ganz toll
dass ich ihre oppositionsrolle ist
vielleicht im gegenteil man heute auch
ich habe sie nicht gefunden werden in
der windel finden wollen also ist ja
auch in ordnung nur noch einmal wie vor
es hat sich den letzten zwei jahren
unter cdu-führung soviel eingeschlichen
an mangelnder parlamentarischer
beteiligung an mangelnder information
und dass von heute auf morgen weg zu
schieben bei dauert ein bisschen sie
müssen sie müssen aber im
gegenteil sie müssen den ministerien
auch erstmal in den ministerien aber es
mal wieder anderes bewusstsein dafür
schärfen dass die auskunftspflicht über
abgeordneten und sie nicht weil ich will
ein
beispiel
dafür wie diese parlamentarische
demokratie in diesen letzten zwei jahren
eingeschläfert wissen das genau das ist
doch ein ganz dicker klops der hier
passiert worden ist und das ist nicht
irgendwas zwischen zwei ministerien
sondern dass sie millionen menschen von
betroffen und so hat zutiefst in ihrem
leben absolut keiner ruft skandal keiner
ruft das wird sofort rückgängig gemacht
der kanzler ist gar nicht zu hören zudem
habe ich mal gut aber das war aber nicht
nur der kanzler auch sonst ist niemand
zu hören man dort ganz sanft miteinander
um bloß den karl lauterbach nicht
bestätigen denn es ist ja noch nicht mal
haben wir wieder den start ganz so
leicht fester werden nur hamm keinen
mehrwert dass hierbei habe ich zeit
darauf hinweisen dass ich in ein blatt
was dieser sendung sehr nahe steht
erklärt habe das ist für mich sinnvoll
erscheint die genesis sechs monate
anzuheben oder aus dem boden lag hatten
ihren runter spacken und deine anderen
anleihen also ich muss mal eins sagen
wenn ich über die politik rede ist
wolfgang kubicki immer ausgenommen
deshalb will ich jetzt ja mit eigenen
verstand durchs leben geht und dass auch
immer wieder zu erkennen gibt das hat
jetzt das ist das wunderbare ist jetzt
mein karriereende was gerade
eine eigene einheit glauben sie dass das
karl lauterbach popularität am ende des
jahres da liegt wo die entspannt
popularität heute liegt nein weil im
gegensatz zu jens spahn carlotta was
tatsächlich nicht nur lernfähig ist und
auch reflektiert jens spahn war gefangen
im politischen macht konstruktion karl
lauterbach hat zwei dinge in seinem
herzen nicht kannst du wieder einmal ist
ein wissenschaftler tatsächlich
und zum anderen sind und zum anderen war
auch in seine eigene fraktion früher
weshalb viele von den kollegen kollegen
gesagt am starken können sie versteht
also dass jemand der einem auf den geist
geht nicht das kann ich mir schon sehr
auf den geist ich bin ich ja aber das
arbeiten noch nicht mal das ja nicht
böse es gibt leute da sagt man jetzt
aber schluss wird noch was trinken und
müssen nicht dauernd über die gleiche
thematik reden aber ich bin sicher dass
er seine eigene innere sorge überwinden
wird dass er alles böse von den menschen
ab halten muss ich bin sicher der wird
in seiner rolle als gesundheitsminister
richtig gut hinein beraten werden und er
wird und er ich weiß dass ich war nicht
dabei nein der wird dann die frage der
politik machen als die allianz ist keine
frage des leiters der minister wird auch
das sehen wird auch der bedarf tag
schwächer er hat relativ klar angefangen
das sehe ich noch er hat sich im ton
zurück genommen er hat sich ähnlich
verhalten wie der kanzler auch der hat
mich weiter angst verbreitet im volk so
und jetzt sehen wir dass rutscht immer
weiter vom blech und was passiert mit
dem man wenn die politik also das
parlament jetzt beschließt die
halbierung des dienstes genesen status
zurückzunehmen gegen seine ausdrückliche
empfehlung er hat ja gerade taufrisch
gesagt er will das nicht er hat auch
bestritten dass er davon wusste
erstaunlicherweise er will das nicht und
dann entscheidet die politik gegen ihn
was macht man da als minister da bleibt
man und sagt das ist halt so eine
parlamentarische demokratie die haben ja
gerade die hosen runtergezogen aber ich
bin auch so noch schön
ja wirklich dass ich jetzt hier
eingeladen so rücktritt also dass das
jetzt hier eingeladen wurde um carlotta
waren der voller breite zu verteilen
müssen immer karte war selbst anlagen
und der wahl ist am sonntag zu gast bei
die richtigen der 100 da war und der
wird jetzt im zweifel auch ordentlich
erklären auch da bin ich mir sicher wenn
karl lauterbach zu anderen
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnis kommen
wissenschaft ist ja dauernd im flow dann
ist ja auch manns genug definitiv
zusagen die entscheidung nehmen wir
zurück